you look like someone I once sent my
daughter to kill I get that a lot
do I get a cool superhero name what do
you think about Plastic Man I think
that's the dumbest name I've ever heard
of DeVoe
you and I have been enemies for years
well you've had others of course there's
dawn soon to follow
this is where we came up with the
cerebral inhibitor to use against the Bo
hey everybody how about plastic man
that's the dumbest name I've ever heard
so this episode was all about
introducing elongated man and breacher
I feel like Danny Trejo totally killed
it but let's do top 10 WTF and comic
book Easter eggs there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video
number 10 breacher breaches in on Cisco
in gypsy as they're getting ready to get
it on while he's also trying to find out
what her real name is
they obviously revealed it by the end
but her real name is Cynthia Moore death
in the comics and even though they had
the joke about Danny Trejo saying his
name was Josh in the comics breachers
real name is quelled more death but I
thought it was totally fine with what
they did in the episode going for the
joke Danny Trejo like pretty much for
the entire first half of his appearance
was nothing but him poking holes in
everything else on the show so far this
facility has very relaxed security your
assistant is a speedster number 9 the
intro to elongated man you'll learn a
little bit about his and Barry's history
and they've pretty much answered all the
questions that they raised in the
episode like they teased this mysterious
falling-out that they had because of
something terrible that elongated man
did or Barry thought that he did
something terrible but then by the end
of the episode they completely wrapped
that up just to let you know that he's
not as big of a dirtbag as he seems when
you first meet him but I think a lot of
us expected that because he's a good
comic book character so they weren't
gonna do the Jay Garrick thing again
where you meet a character that you
think is good but he turns out he's
super evil so number 8 he's confirmed as
the next meta bus even though he lied
about how he got his powers initially he
was on the bus he's so poor that he had
to give the bus driver in IO
you and the thinker is the one that sort
of created the circumstances of the
episode that lead the mayor to try and
end up killing him because of the
blackmail but we didn't really see him
in the episode we only got his name at
the end so I'll explain that big twist
so even if you don't see him in an
episode he at this very moment is
probably watching everything that
they're doing number seven though they
finally pay off the Cecile is pregnant
twist from last week's episode there
were a couple funny job reactions too
like after that big WTF save in the
helicopter where he just spits it right
out like he'd been lying to Barry for
the entire episode you know I'm not
glowing for any particular reason so one
is great to see them celebrate about
that they haven't turned it into a
bigger thing than that like right now
we're just meant to think that this is a
happy occurrence yeah you know who knew
Joe at this age would have another child
but I think we're all expecting them to
turn that into some big twist later on
like maybe Daniel West will come along
or it'll be something different it'll be
some twist on the idea Barry and Iris's
twins from the comics but there were a
couple of other foreshadowing moments in
the episode like things that they set up
that I think they'll pay off in future
episodes the idea that Joe is really
good the mayor used to be a cop I think
they're trying to paint Joe is a
potential future leader like maybe he'll
become the police captain in a future
episode they just want to make it sound
like he's capable of doing things more
than what he's doing right now being a
detective number six all of breachers
jokes inside STAR Labs when he says
there's no resemblance to him in gypsy
he's talking about the actors in real
life like there are two different actors
cast to play characters and they don't
look anything alike
he says that they have very terrible
security Barry agrees yeah pretty much
anybody could break into STAR Labs you
look like somebody I sent my daughter to
kill last year he's talking about HR
gypsy was actually sent in episode 12 I
think it was we first met her to go get
him and bring him back that's one of
their biggest crimes because they have
the big Runner in the episode - your
people destroyed my world I won't allow
you to live there was also the joke
where gypsy told Cisco that he literally
killed somebody just with a look they
just want to make him seem really badass
like Cisco picks up the machete off of
the table a reference to Danny Trejo
Chetty movies he says that this is
predator and he's the Schwarzenegger
character breacher also pulls a special
knife that's almost big enough to be a
machete to cut himself out of that
reverse-flash force field he was good
enough for the reverse-flash that was
way back in season one when Cisco first
learned his identity it was even a
Princess Bride reference where someone
said have fun storming the castle number
six in the copy shop breacher reminds us
about the invasion on earth nineteen the
way they destroy the copy crop if you
remember last year when [ __ ]
guest-starred in a couple episodes she
took home those giant bags of copy
because they didn't have copy anymore
the creatures that invaded their earth
from another dimension were called the
plastids even though that name is
actually the name of a Marvel character
it's also the name of the stuff that's
used to make Darth Vader's armor but I
think that he was actually talking about
the blight because they say a blight
destroyed their coffee crop the blight
is actually this alien race that looks
much more menacing this actually looks
like something that would invade your
earth and try to destroy you so when he
looks at elongated man and thinks that
he's one of the plasters I think he's
actually talking about these creatures
he rattles off a laundry list of names
of really dangerous people that he's
hunted down and killed like Morla
Salonga scars those are all obscure
characters from the comics and then
number five you have sort of the mystery
about what happened between barry in
elongated man so there were a couple of
references back to season one moments
Barry's mother's murder what happened to
his father they did a good job of
weaving that with the backstory for
Ralph did me so the whole thing that got
him kicked off of the force was about a
year before the events of season one
there was a murder they thought the
husband did it but they didn't have
enough evidence so Ralph's Dib knee
planted evidence berry later found out
about it told on him
so the husband went free but I was sort
of expecting them to give him an out so
that he wouldn't seem like quite the
dirtbag and it turns out Dib knee who's
actually a really good detective better
than Barry knew that the husband was
guilty but they didn't have the right
kind of evidence so he was just looking
for a way to put him behind bars but I
guess the way they ended the episode
made it seem like they're kind of cool I
think they just implies what their
relationship is gonna be like like they
won't hate each other outright they'll
be a little more
in a fun way like the way that Harrison
wells and Cisco are buddies even though
Harrison wells acts like he hates Cisco
sometimes but number four is Barry
phasing through the floor to get rid of
the bomb all kinds of new powers this
year or using powers in ways that you
haven't seen before he ran along
elongated man's arm he also ate a bullet
so the idea that he's bulletproof might
help save somebody in the back half of
the season the way that the face
changing device debuted in episode six
of season three and then that ended up
being part of the big twist of how HR
fooled savat AR into thinking that he
was iris so anything that seems like a
really small beat but kind of cool right
now usually ends up becoming a much
bigger thing in the back half of the
season but number three you have
Caitlin's storyline she tries to defend
him villains can turn good again because
she's still wrestling with being killer
frost and Caitlin like she's actually
lying to everyone by saying the killer
frost is gone when she's not we'll see
her again later this season and it's all
about what blacksmith is doing Katee
Sackhoff scare achter who was the big
twist at the end of the episode who had
sort of carved that into her door so
that's sort of a way to tee up more of
the killer frost storyline that they're
gonna pay off in next week's episode
number two was Barry inviting him to be
on the team at STAR Labs Luke will help
you with your powers he tries to give
him the Plastic Man name if you're not a
big comic book reader Plastic Man is a
different character from the elongated
man they were actually characters that
DC acquired from other companies like
they both got their start at separate
miner comic book companies the DC comics
later bought so eventually you had a
couple different characters with the
same types of powers even though they're
completely different if you're a big
comic book reader too dark nights metal
Plastic Man is a big part of that
they've been carrying around his egg the
last couple of issues Barry says that
Cisco is the one that's good at naming
people so he'll probably get his
elongated man name either next week
maybe the week after that sometime soon
but the number one twist is obviously
Barry hearing the name to vote and then
sort of putting all the pieces together
oh my god that was the name that
Savatage said he's the one that's behind
all this stuff that's been happening so
presumably they'll follow up with that
at the beginning of next week's episode
they've been celebrating Joe's pregnancy
so they might wait just a B maybe after
the bachelor parties
but as
with the progression each season usually
they find out who the villain is and
they find out a little bit more about
what's going on with them before they
actually fight each other that usually
winds up being the big battle during the
mid-season finale but let me know in the
comments what was your favorite new
ability that they did in this whether it
was the flash or elongated man and what
do you think the thinker is going to try
and do to turn elongated man back to his
team so what I'll do is I'll post that
trailer video tomorrow morning there's
also a new Titans video we might
actually get Roy Harper on Titan season
1 so congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner at Kezia Holland please
private message me so I can get your
contact details you can click here to
listen to Henry Cavill in the rock talk
about Black Adam and Superman post
Justice League and you can click here
for brand new Star Wars thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight